اللافت ان السماء السوريه تزخر او تزدحم
بالطائرات غارات متزامنه باهداف مختلفه
بداتها اسرائيل وتبعتها تركيا وختمتها
روسيا الى الان على الاقل كانت الايام
القليله الماضيه مرهقه اكثر من اي وقت مضى
بالنسبه لمراقبه طائرات كانت مرهقه لهم
عبرت القوات الجويه
لثلاث دول سماء سوريا عبرت عن قوتها هناك
عندما عبرت في تلك السماء وقصفت اهدافا في
ساحل المتوسط منه الى صحار الشرق سنه كل
من تركيا واسرائيل وروسيا غارات في الايام
الاخيره مؤكده من جديد ان الحرب المستمره
منذ عقد من الزمن لا تزال صراعا مفتوحا مع
امكانيات التصعيد على الثلاث جهات على
الاقل
[موسيقى]
بدا وقبل القذف في ساعه المبكره من صباح
السبت عندما استهدفت غارات اسرائيليه
مواقع عده على طول الساحل السوري وفي قلب
البلاد تحديدا مدن اللاذقيه وحما وحمس
اسفرت الغارات عن مقتل اربعه من عناصر
النظام السوري في احدث سلسله من الضربات
ضد اهداف تابعه لمليشيات حزب الله
اللبنانيه الايراني
كرديه في شمال شرق سوريا قبل ان يطلق
الرئيس التركي تهديداته بعمليه بريه وشيكه
كما ذكرنا عمليه عسكريه جويه مستمره اعلنت
خلالها وزاره الدفاع التركيه قتل عشرات
المسلحين من وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
المرتبطه بحزب العمال الكردستاني المصنف
في تركيا
من الذي بقي بقيت روسيا التي شاركت صباح
الاثنين بقصف استهدف مناطق ريفيه في
محافظه ادلب بالقرب من الحدود التركيه
ومواقع مدنيه بالقرب من مخيمين للاجئين
تنقل صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه عن نازح
سوري في ادلب قوله ان الجميع يتحكمون في
سماءنا غارات اسرائيل وتركيا وروسيا بانها
مثل الصقور التي تلتقط الارانب
صحيفه نقلت عن الدكتوره لينا الخطيب وهي
مديره برنامج الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
في مركز الابحاث توتنهام هاوس قولها ان
الحرب في سوريا تخاطر بان تصبح صراعا
منسيا
لكن الضربات الجويه المستمره من قبل تركيا
وروسيا واسرائيل تظهر ان المصالح
الاقليميه لا تزال فعاله اذ تستهدف كل
دوله من الدول الثلاث خصومها لمنعهم من
تعزيز نفوذهم في سوريا
يمثل هذا تذكيرا بان الصراع السوري ليس
صراعا منعزلا ولا حربا اهليه اذ لطالما
لعبت المصالح الاقليميه والدوليه الدوله
الاكبر وتهدف الغارات التركيه والروسيه
والاسرائيليه المتكرره الى حمايه تلك
المصالح
[موسيقى]